I'm here with reaction the host of
Justice with judge Jeanine Pirro judge
any court you know that you walk into an
America I have to go through a metal
detector anyone I've ever been in I also
have to present an ID in any court I've
ever been to every time I've been to
Congress every RNC convention every DNC
convention every ballgame I go to and
every office building in New York can we
not do something better instead of the
same old arguments well you know Shawn
you're so right and and what you said
certainly rang true to me where whenever
something like this happens we go to the
old argument the second of members say
the Second Amendment people say you know
the right of the individual to possess a
bear arms shall not be infringed and
then on the left they say that guns kill
people I think shooters killed people
but let me start by saying Shawn number
one that as a DA I would often have to
tell a parent that their child was a
victim of a homicide so my heart goes
out to all of those parents and all of
those people who knew the victims here
but we need to be very clear this is not
a political issue this is not an issue
about the left and the right and the NRA
actually I'm sticking here on the NRA
and in the interest of full disclosure
let me say I have many guns I have long
guns I have handguns but this is really
about the individual and in this case an
individual who not only threatened and
posted himself on YouTube as someone who
wanted to be a professional school
shooter but that individual had been
expelled from school he had all kinds of
personal problems and yet he was able to
purchase a gun
why was he able to purchase a gun
because background checks to be honest
with you are a joke in the sense that if
you're on psychotropic drugs if you've
been in a mental institution if it law
protects us and I used to sign pistol
permits all the time as a judge it
prevents us the HIPAA laws from finding
out what your mental history is so all
the wackadoo from Adam Lanza and all the
school shooters Aurora Columbine they
can get a gun with no problem although
some of them got them for their parents
but that's not the point you are
absolutely right we need to protect kids
and that means we've got have metal
detectors we've got to have experienced
cops I don't care if they're retired or
the still cops working in the schools
and we've got to be able to have
perimeter controls we've got to have
police teachers who can carry a weapon
and react to this kind of nonsense
because our kids deserve our protection
Sean you know it look I'm not saying
it's a good night it's I know schools
that right now if you're a parent
there's only one door you're getting in
that they do have security at these
these schools there's only one door and
even if they know you I've gone into
schools where hi mr. Hannity I need your
ID first thing they would say yeah you
know and you know it's you can do that
at a building in New York City they'll
say hi judge Jeanine do you have your ID
wait a minute then we're in New York
City you know who I am but but I agree
with you Sean
what we had here though was a warning
that we haven't had in other cases and
with all due respect to the FBI if they
deserve it based on everything we're
hearing about I don't want to hear
another FBI agent go up to a microphone
and say we had no further identifying
information wait a minute you're the FBI
some guy did the right thing and he
called you and he said this kid that's
on YouTube saying I want to be a
professional school shooter how many
people in this country have the name
Nicholas Cruz how many people in this
country have the name Nicholas with a k'
how many of them have bought a gun if we
learned anything from 911 it's that the
federal agencies don't connect with each
other this kid who all the warnings were
there all they needed to do was connect
the dots and they didn't know I think
judges you you couldn't say any better
all right we appreciate your insight and
we'll be watching you this weekend and
you're in for me tomorrow night and
people will be watching thanks judge